to the reporter right before you Mark
Martin you know made a great point about
how this is not just about FIFA but this
is this is about other sports other
sports leagues you know is there when
you have this much concentrated power in
the hands of few you know you know does
that then encourage you know malpractice
like this is this just the beginning of
what we might see a wave of corruption
probes into other sports and other
leaves well we know that there's been
corruption in sports for a long time I
mean it's it's a high-stakes game it has
a lot to do with a country self-esteem
and how they perform on the highest
stage and certainly we're very aware as
Americans what metal counts look like
and what winning trophies looks like so
we're interested in that and that's
something that politicians pay close
attention to so has there been other
corruption before absolutely and and has
there been a history and a pattern of
corruption and a variety of sports
absolutely people are always looking for
an edge but I absolutely agree with your
reporter on the ground this is longer
longer and larger than just the the vote
today there are going to be some real
ramifications for the north american
soccer league for concave off' and some
other organizations that have been
associated with these media and
marketing companies i Karen a morning if
you could describe what it must be like
to be an advertiser or a sponsor of for
example World Cup soccer what does that
mean well right now there are some folks
who are projecting as much as a 1
billion dollar loss in brand equity
brand value across the platform if in
fact these sponsors stay with FIFA and
so that's a fundamental decision that
sponsors are trying to decide right now
we know that FIFA already lost two major
sponsors last summer in Sony and amorous
and those those companies made a
decision that they just didn't want to
be associated with this kind of behavior
a lot of other sponsors now are taking a
good hard look I'd say even more deeply
than possibly some of the sponsors
indicated in the NFL and the Ray Rice
scandal last September but Karen if this
doesn't keep
fans away though I mean if attendance is
going to continue to grow right with
each world cup and and football fever
continues to grow around the world I
mean eventually those sponsors are going
to come back right that's that's the
age-old issue you want to be where the
fans are but the problem is is that what
line do you say this is our value
structure and our value structure
doesn't match up with their value
structure and sponsors make those kinds
of calculations all the time when
they're trying to sponsor an individual
athlete or sponsoring a team or even
entire world event like the World Cup